so as we're building out our purchase
flow whenever things with my twitch with
which we became I team two is the
importance of making sure people feel
comfortable putting their payment
information into the purchase experience
and so one thing
wait which we did learn is that like
it's important to offer multiple
different options because different
buyers have different levels of
appreciation of the security as you're
going through the purchase flow and
surprise like that and then being able
to offer both the credit card option or
like offering like a paypal option and
so I think I traditionally on its kind
of understood to try to make a purchase
experience as as simple as possible like
to move all the different options but
but particularly like as you think about
payments creating options which give the
sense of security was a pretty important
as we build out this experience